With negative signs, reciprocals and exponents you want to be very careful. Math
requires a keen attention to detail. Let's look at a couple of scenarios when
we'll be working with negatives, so that way you can see what I mean. We have to
be careful. Here I know it's just 5 squared or 5 times 5, so I get 25. For
negative 5 squared, I have the whole quantity of negative 5 squared, so I write
the whole thing in parentheses twice, so I have negative 5 times negative 5. I
know a negative times a negative is a positive, so I get 25. Here I have to
remember back to my order of operations. Do exponents or the subtraction take
precedence. I know exponents come first. Here I have a choice. I could have the
5 be negative, and then I can square it or I could square the 5 and then take
the negative. Remember back from the order of operations, we know exponents come
first. So I'll have 5 squared and then I'll have it multiplied by negative 1.
Oftentimes we don't show the multiplication here, but that's really what we
mean. It's negative 1 times 5. This is why we have to be really careful about
what we need in math. That's why a lot of times we use parentheses, we want to
know if we're scoring in 5, negative 5, or if we're scoring a number and then
multiplying it by negative 1, they're all different. So for my answer I have
negative 1 times 25, or negative 25, and finally 5 to the negative 2. Remember,,
with negative exponents, we really do the reciprocal. So I'm going to have 1
over 5 and that's going to be squared. So I have 1 5th times 1 5th, or 1 25th.